have you ever read an anime description
for show you just watch and you were
just like man this is this is nothing
about where the show is actually about
yeah most of the descriptions I find
don't really contain the information we
need either they over sell something or
under sell something or aren't really
indicative to the watching experience of
the anime so I thought I'd play a fun
game for myself see if I could fix some
anime descriptions to contain the
information that we really need to know
all right so let's start off with
something I'm sure we can all agree with
you know something very very simple you
know an easy quick fix
Foca no pico stopped recommending this
animates people your pieces of [__]
Yukiteru Yukiya Amano is a loner who
never already interacts with people and
defers writing a diary on his cellphone
with his only companion being an
imaginary friends manged a ex marketer
the god of time and space blah blah blah
battle royale blah blah diary game blah
blah predicting the future okay you get
the point mercy this is the perfect
example of a description that
desperately needs fixing it's too tame
it makes it sound way more complex than
it actually is and it doesn't even
mention the entire reason it got so
popular let's be real about this
Yukiteru Yukiya Amano is a [__] loser
who's so pathetic his only real friend
he's a talking knockoff Metal Gear in
his head one day he meets the thirstiest
[__] in existence and joins a
competition to kill off most poorly
written characters using the power of
his magical Twitter accounts edge ensues
hands up where she heard of the word
yandere before the show ever came out
yeah I think I think that should about
do it
oh come on alright this should be pretty
easy I mean everyone grew up with this
after he turns 10 years old Ash Ketchum
Satoshi in Japan start his journey oh
God Jesus Wikipedia do we really need
the page worth of plot summary to
explain Pokemon it's really not that
complicated
look let me condense down some of this
fat for you elemental cockfighting is
legal and no one bats an eye
join Ash Ketchum when his journey of
never winning never achieving his dreams
and always falling short cuz last
[__] life kids it's been 20 goddamn
years now he still looks like he just
graduated from middle school yes you
really wasted your childhood in this
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure now how do we
even begin to describe this anime well
actually it's pretty simple but we're
not gonna give the series much justice
with this description look you miss
JoJo's there's only one real way to
describe it okay well our story starts
in 1868 where Dario Brando discovers a
crash scene wearing
nobleman George Joestar Lane George
toaster weights up in mistakes Daria for
saving his life and ask about the
well-being of his wife and baby to wish
Dario respond
and this is when savelii first appears
who introduces jonathan to the concept
of ripples now ripple is one of the
power mechanics used at the beginning of
jojo's you see and it's summed up quite
simply yeah yeah we all know the reason
we watch highschool to death haha yeah
baby so why the hell is there no mention
of this in any description anywhere
anywhere monsters high school come on
guys we can do better than this imagine
a world where every girl Authority waxed
with a car buffer joins a Keshi in the
survival harem story as he watches
funbags bouncing around at the speed of
sound with the odd actual scene
dispersed in-between boobs boobs ass ass
boobs boobs directed by Michael Bay oh
and there are zombies I guess it's like
an anime set in Nazi Germany
except Hitler wasn't just a ruthless
dictator but also a hyperactive [__] as
well and Nazi Germany was a high school
and there were time travelers and
Esper's and aliens and a sarcastic get
monologuing about it every five seconds
scratch that it's nothing like Marcy
Germany except for Hitler bombs and that
about wraps up the first part phantom
blood now part 2 battle dependencies
when we were introduced to Joseph
Joestar he's the son of Jonathan Joestar
and is actually living in New York where
he himself he meets a kiichi Onizuka a
22 year old ex biker and college karate
champ he's crude foul-mouthed and has a
hair-trigger temper blah blah blah there
he uses his street smarts to deal with
colleagues and students alike come on
crunchyroll I know you can do better
than this I mean I know onizuka's a
feel-good show and whatnot and sure he's
crude and foul-mouthed but using his
street smarts to deal with colleagues
and students let's not undersell it here
a short-tempered pervert lands luckiest
teaching gig of his life through his
loving methods of physical and mental
abuse violence bribery torture and
blackmail he teaches his students to
become outstanding members of society
remember kids if in doubt just be a
[__]
[Music]
at the same time in the year 2010 the
holy Empire of Britannia is establishing
itself as a dominant military nation
starting with the conquest boring
politics politics politics who cares
about that how are we ever gonna appeal
to the Millennials of this age and we
don't spice this up a bit hey kids do
you like prank channels or join one man
on this journey of staging the most epic
prank of all time but don't forget it
was just the brag bro just don't tell
the government you're actually watching
a show about terrorism PS use coupon
code geass for 10 percent of your next
meal at Pizza Hut it's a dick metaphor
everything's a dick metaphor this entire
shows a dick metaphor I think it'd mean
more dick metaphors alright one punch
man with a title like one punch man it
should be pretty simple to describe what
one punch man is about right so why the
hell do we need all this don't worry
though I got you covered
one punch man details the struggle of a
man working through the biggest first
world problem anyone has ever had to
deal with everything else you need to
know is in the [__] title ticket no
for [__] sake this concept does not
get boring and so do now is actually
back by stealing the body of Jonathan
Joestar and so Joseph Joestar who is now
an old man travels to Japan with his
acquaintances from Egypt to meet his
grandson Jotaro every so often there
comes a show that breaks the
preconceived norms and challenges your
perception of the world what is
acceptable what isn't acceptable why is
it that the rules of society are shaped
the way they are and how did social
convention evolve to lead us where we
are now these questions and more play an
intrical part in understanding why we
think the way we do which is why today I
present to you animals you'd like to
[__] look you're just an anime about
swimming swimming swimming I'm kidding
guys let's be real here this show has
nothing to do with swimming three tales
of a romance stories through the ages
given the first ever recorded accounts
of a man whose sexual preference is
water some other people may also tell
you that this show is about ships which
is
fusing because I couldn't see any ships
whatsoever one of the greatest anime
films come out of the modern era wolf
children tells a tale of a mother
desperately trying to raise a half wolf
offspring mama reverse Oda delivers his
magnum opus in this beautiful rendition
of a tale of parenthood
and raising children just [__] a wolf
alright you know what I've had enough of
doing this long wait let's just go to
the lightning round twice and wolf naked
furries can make literally anything
interesting even economics PS [__] gets
really good in season three school days
man [__] anything with a vagina it
doesn't matter
donk you know Tara not 11 II was
actually planned by the Japanese death
notes Zakia front rises down TARDIS to
remove a bunch of letters from the
alphabet Tokyo ghoul a kid just
desperately wants to dies here white but
has no idea how to go about doing it
Stein's gates a bunch of [__] sticking
around with a microwave breaks the
space-time continuum Italia casual
racism is acceptable in Japan Angel
Beats
one man finds the most complete way ever
to have a hard heart with someone and
that's all we had time for today next
time will be given accurate descriptions
of some of your favorite shitty waifu's
so if you want to join in on that leave
me your accurate descriptions of some of
your shitty wifey's here let me get us
started sending a hara anorexic
sarcastic [__] who also has crabs hey
guys hope you enjoyed the video thank
you very much this month to un thing
Jerrica tell Tony lo gay brown and
everyone else ports me on patreon for
making this video possible
this is just a dumb little video I came
up with to reuse some father's
scriptures I wrote spore reviews that
were never finished over the years as
I'm spending most of my time working on
anime 2016 this month if you like see
more of my stuff you can click on the
annotations on this video and you can
also follow me on Facebook and Twitter
too anyway that's it for me
I've been gig oak and I'll see you all
next time